[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today today's
question comes from Chris in Michigan I
know this may be a silly question to ask
however I if I hear your advice on this
I might feel much better a couple of
weeks ago I went to the grocery store to
get a few snacks and items for the week
and the total cost was $100 With Coupons
then on my social media I started seeing
reals and Tik Tok videos about how bad
inflation is today compared to the 1980s
and
90s uh they say that
$300,000 is the new $100,000 in buying
power for homes or to be considered well
off is this what is what I am seeing
just more than inflation fear porn or is
everything getting worse out there and
I'm just now noticing what are your
thoughts thank you and God bless ooh
okay so Rachel I've seen these videos
there's this real estate guy out there
who makes all these videos comparing
the 1950s and 60s and 70s and the prices
then versus What It Takes now and the
income's now and how much more
impossible it feels yep and all it is is
really ring people up to get clicks and
Views and the data is skewed I mean even
on that video it said it has one of
those like context needed click here
like one of those warnings from
Instagram that's like this isn't totally
factual this was taken out of context
from this data from 1950s that only took
into account this and that so I'm not
I'm not sitting here at a par out this
guy's data and debunk it but is
inflation really that bad for some
people and if you follow the Ramsey plan
and you've been on a budget and you've
stayed out of debt inflation feels more
like a pinch than a punch and depending
on where you are and your housing market
and your lifestyle and if you're in
Canada goodness gracious our our friends
in Canada are going through it Rachel
with their food prices alone right but
is it worse than it ever has been maybe
is it going to crush your life
financially and there's no way to
survive it we need to shake our fists at
the inflation Gods until they do
something about it no so I think it
largely is kind of that inflation fear
porness he said and there's a lot we can
do about it which is comforting but I
also don't want to minimize the fact
that it's hard I mean there yeah and I
think there's a reality to like the real
estate side of it right I'm like it's
yeah houses are insane interest rates
are insane but it's also perspective
because when you look back at certain
times even in the 80s what interest r
were on houses it was like 16 18% right
for for mortgages and if it dropped to
12% everyone went crazy and so we're at
you know that sevenish percent and from
our perspective especially if you're a
millennial and when you're if you went
and bought a house you know your first
house 10 12 years ago and you lived in
the 2% world for so long that became
normal and then all of a sudden when it
jumps up it does feel like oh my gosh
this is insane but it's been more insane
in the past right so I think it's all
it's all
perspective and yeah I mean I think I
mean you look at tuition for college is
insane uh I mean there's just things
that yeah I think the math can prove it
out but it doesn't mean that it's
impossible it may mean that there's
going to be more patience and you have
to be more on a plan be more intentional
because one more reason to get out of
debt too yeah if you need margin one of
the things stealing from your margin is
your debt and so getting out of debt is
a huge help if you're feeling the pinch
of and I would say this too and I'm not
a historical Economist George I know you
may think that
I but I'm not but I would say life is
like it is a roller coaster it is up and
down and there's going to be good times
there's going to be bad times you know
you look at 08 and what the housing
market was it's the opposite and you
know what it is now in the sense of like
how expensive houses are so things
fluctuate in life there's an election
year coming up next year that always
kind of changes the economy to a degree
people hold on to their money they wait
and see I mean things just they shift
all the time so to be in this permanent
mindset that this is how it's going to
be forever and ever amen it's just not
true so well Rachel you always say you
know comparing your life to someone
else's is always going to end just kind
of drinking your own poison in a sense
and so the same goes for comparing your
life to the folks of the 1980s and the
70s and the 60s and first of all do you
understand the standard of life we now
have y'all need to get a new iPhone
every single year they didn't even have
a smartphone look at the car I was going
to say they were usually a onecar family
the square footage average square
footage of what a home was in the8
there was no white cabinets there were
all these small dilapidated homes and
Dinky cars and no one cared but now we
have social Med seat belts remember
those days George walk around the van
that's we simpler times Rachel's walking
around the van while it's going 90 miles
down the interstate it's just it was a
different world y'all in so many ways
and so yeah to your point George if you
just sit there and complain about it
sure it hurts and you're like man that'
been nice to have bought a house 5 years
ago sure but you didn't
so you are where you are now so what are
we going to do about it there's a level
of like this reality and if you just sit
in this I can tell you what doesn't help
the Boomers Doom scrolling Instagram is
not going to get you any closer to your
financial goals so uh you can hit heart
on his thing and leave a comment say oh
my gosh he's so right life is so hard or
you can just get up and go to work and
take the side job and get out of debt
and do the hard stuff to get to where
you want to go but I I see both sides of
this Corin this those platforms George
as you know fill um continue to fill
your feed with what you watch that's
right so I opened mine up and it was all
T Swift coming out of a New York
restaurant with all her friends because
obviously that's what I've been looking
at recently so there she all was so if
you're Doom scrolling to your point and
you have like these like you need to be
swift scrolling you yeah just change to
something happier so at least you're not
being continually fed this fear so
remember that too Taylor Swift Paparazzi
videos that's the positivity we need in
today's sometimes she just seen to
escape from real